the left thinks it's dangerous to
investigate Hunter Biden days after two
IRS whistleblowers gave jaw-dropping
testimony exposing how the Biden doj
went easy on the first son's tax probe
Democrats in the media are teaming up to
take them down
the circus has come to town with the
House GOP and what's dangerous about
this is that the American people and
their needs are not part of their agenda
and they want to focus on this political
theater Republicans are going to point
to this continuously as a clear sign of
wrongdoing or potential wrongdoing and
use it to continue to bolster these
investigations that we saw them do
earlier this week with IRS so-called
whistleblowers about Hunter Biden we
have all of these so-called
whistleblowers who again admit
the Trump justice department said yeah
there's nothing there oh So speaking of
that testimony tune into Special Report
right after the five for an exclusive
interview with Iris whistleblower Joseph
Ziegler here he is responding to
democratic attacks
several of the Democrats on the
committee said these are just the kind
of dust ups that investigators and
prosecutors have you're not always going
to be on the same page is that accurate
criminal investigations when you work a
criminal case there's a thing called
willfulness whether someone
intentionally with knowledge either
evaded their income taxes or filed a
false return and that's what one thing
that sets us apart from a civil case and
in this case we provided a ton of
evidence that showed willfulness
the Democrats are also really not going
to like this an unclassified FBI
document released Yesterday by Senator
Grassley exposes an alleged bribery
scheme involving both Joe and Hunter the
memo claims the then Vice President
Biden and his son coerced the CEO of
barisma to pay them 10 million dollars
in exchange for help in getting the
Ukrainian prosecutor investigating the
company fired the New York Post
publishing this op-ed calling for a
special counsel to investigate the
allegations so judge it's interesting
because you read through that FBI
document that was released yesterday
that was obtained by Grassley through a
whistleblower because the FBI refused to
turn it over for months on end and it
reads more like Joe was demanding
payment rather than barisma offering
bride the interesting thing is the 1023
that you referred to that the FBI was
reluctant to hand over initially they
said they didn't have it okay so now
Grassley releases it we have a copy of
the 1023 and the amazing part of it is
all zlav chesky who is the guy who was
in barisma who's paying out the money he
says that the bidens were paid through
so many different bank accounts it would
take investigators 10 years to unravel
okay and now you've got Comer and the
rest of them and they say all this money
the 17 million and the 10 million is
from One bank so we haven't seen all of
it yet and the amazing part of this is
now we know according to this verifiable
FBI confidential informant who was paid
upwards of 200 000 by the FBI because
they believed in what he said it was
effective in prosecutions he says there
are up to 17 tapes two of those tapes
include the voice of Joe Biden and he
talks about the fact that um in Europe
this guys love chesky hired someone to
cover him in Europe and in the United
States he hired Hunter Biden to protect
us through his dad from all kind kinds
of problems and he says Hunter is so
dumb that this guy's dog is smarter than
Hunter and so you look at this and you
say and then you hear someone who just
said I saw it on the sound there that
this was during the Trump Administration
and
um that they didn't do anything with it
the truth is or that they passed on it
yeah they said nothing the truth is that
they weren't aware of what was going on
that the FBI kept as close to their vest
they didn't investigate this even though
Bill Barr was a United States Attorney
no one moved on this which is why they
were so willing to say we don't have it
but it's all here it's everything that
you need for a prosecutor so Jessica
would you be open to a special counsel
to look into this situation sure if
that's what what's necessary they're
like a dime a dozen now everyone's got
one but put a special Counsel on it but
you should also take these Republicans
at their word and they've been
commenting on the contents of this 1023
so Chuck Grassley has said in interviews
that the bribery allegation may not be
true Ron Johnson has said take it with a
grain of salt Congressman Chuck Edwards
seems like the only honest Republican on
the oversight committee said that
President Biden hasn't been implicated
then you look at someone like Jim Comer
who's on the most embarrassing press
tour and should really stop doing
interviews he's on Ted Cruz's podcast
today and Ted Cruz says you know what's
going on here and he says well Biden's
been selling access for decades and Ted
Cruz responsibly says well how do you
know that and Jim Comer says if you
study Joe Biden like I have he's always
been cash strapped okay well that means
that you took 10 million dollars from
ukrainians also this Victor shoken a
controversy about the Ukrainian
prosecutor that was fired
this story has been gone over a million
times that prosecutor was removed by the
entire Western Community by the prime
minister of the UK French Germans the
IMF Senate Republicans supported
removing him because the guy was not
investigating corruption it actually
ended up hurting berysma to remove
Victor shoken from his position and I
see you're snickering and you'll go next
and I get it and I'll try to interrupt
you and it probably won't be uh won't be
allowed or you'll say I haven't
interrupted you I I'm just previewing
what will come you can't pre-buttal an
interruption did you guys order the
appetizers because we I have to work on
my other table
I'm done all right well listen I don't
want a special counsel I want
impeachment proceedings all right these
people they say this is political
theater they did two years on January
six hearings ignoring inflation and eye
crime and then the guy says so-called
whistleblowers what's a so-called
whistleblower he means a whistleblower
and then they say Trump Justice said
nothing there there no they went in at
May 2020 Barr looked at it sent it to
Delaware where it died where everything
dies and so you got a highly credible
informant who's been with the FBI for
decades and he submits this report
saying that this guy's bragging about
having the bribe 10 million to the Biden
family to get this prosecutor fired and
he's got 17 tapes Joe's on two of them
Hunters on 15 of them and they say it's
unverified yeah you're right Jessica it
is unverified let's go verify it let's
everything's unverified if it's a claim
they took the dossier an unverified
dossier used it to get a wire up on the
Trump campaign they didn't say it
unverified they just said this guy's
dirty because he's Russian that's bogus
another thing Joe Biden and all these
guys got together in the west and said
yeah we got to get rid of the prosecutor
because everyone wants Joe Biden to be
right no because he had the Polish guy
on the on the chair of the board too
they had Americans the polls you know
how this works Jessica right they get so
defensive about this because if it were
just Hunter Biden they would let it go
and let him go but it gets too close to
Joe Biden which is why they get so I
feel kind of bad for Hunter uh I've been
thinking about this a lot you know he
didn't have any idea that his dad was
going to actually run for president so
he did his job which was to get Joe Rich
he made it rain right he didn't thought
2016 was the last year I'm gonna make us
some money I'm going to be swimming in
prostitutes and crack for the rest of my
life and then what happens his dad
becomes president and then all of this
stuff comes out the problem is there's
so much stuff right there's a multitude
of malfeasances and it's also
complicated my head hurts and I think
that when you're never going to have a
good outcome if the thing you're yelling
is 10 23 because people are at home are
like 10 23 is that a tax form so what
what month is this so you have to like
you have to prioritize these things the
one you had the FBI slow walking the
investigation into Hunter's taxes you
have the 10 23. see I just did that
because I'm lazy I didn't want to say
the whole letter documents the bride
document it's better but the big deal I
think out of this is if the FBI
revealing that they knew the laptop was
real the day the New York Post article
came out and they didn't fess up they
suggested otherwise you had that letter
you had the public believing one thing
that wasn't true and that's and that the
irony of that is that's how you got
President Biden if that if that if that
had gone the way it should have followed
the truth Trump would have won and then
we'd be talking about of course Trump's
15th impeachment instead of these Heroes
all we want is the truth
and I need a cough drop okay hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else